lantern festivals date back more than 2
000 years and we have our very own now
in henderson at cowabunga bay the water
park officially turned into a holiday
wonderland or it does so on friday and
rocky stopped by to get a sneak peek of
the art and experiences to come
we are standing underneath the lantern
arch which is a beautiful way to
celebrate the festival of lanterns among
you're one of the owners of the company
that brought all of this magical artwork
to calabanga bay i have a feeling
there's some symbolism to this arch what
does it mean yeah it means wealth luck
love and fortune wow that's beautiful
and what was the process i see one of
your incredible artists here working and
doing some finishing touches because the
festival of lanterns is finally open to
the public on friday so what was the
process like mung to bring this artwork
here what did it take how long wow about
seven to nine months so we produced
something in the factory in china we had
also we use
ocean fried two sheep everything here
then we finish the production here with
another uh one month then use the half a
month to pro install everything
so that's the whole process oh my
goodness there's so much work that goes
into something so beautiful it is all
worthwhile and what's the what are the
materials because this feels like silk
this feels like real silk yeah it is it
is silk cloth which is waterproof
fireproof also
uv proof which is perfect for las vegas
weather right absolutely and what does
it mean to you to bring your culture to
las vegas like this okay for me
personally in the photographing group
our goal is bring the culture to the
whole world and use culturally way to
exchange to communicate to touch
people's hearts because we want to make
the communities full of more harmony
happier and after people suffer so much
we want to give people some comforts
through
you through artworks you know so this is
very unique bring your families and
friends here absolutely and on behalf of
the entire vegas community thank you for
bringing this here this is incredible
you can enjoy it through february and of
course they're going to have different
holiday experiences throughout the
coming months so you have to check in to
keep up with that so come down starting
on friday you can see this at night all
lit up at cowabunga bay i'll send it
back to you thank you guys